[Música]
el ex presidente estadounidense donald
trump se negó a declarar frente a la
fiscal general de nueva york- tromba
está investigado por sus prácticas
comerciales y el negocio inmobiliario de
su familia del exmandatario denuncia una
persecución
el abogado del presidente de perú pedro
castillo renunció a la defensa del
mandatario y a la de su esposa pero tras
reunirse con él en el palacio de
gobierno anunció que vuelve a defenderlo
esto luego de que varias personas del
entorno cercano castillo fueran
arrestadas y su cuñada investigada por
presunta corrupción se entregara a las
autoridades
de méjico el rescate de los diez mineros
atrapados en una mina de carbón entra en
una nueva etapa el primer equipo de
rescatistas logró ingresar a uno de los
túneles pero todavía hay obstáculos que
dificultarían la extracción tenemos
reportes desde la capital mexicana
hola bienvenidos a las noticias de
américa en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos en eeuu el ex
presidente de donald trump se acogió a
la quinta enmienda en el interrogatorio
de la fiscalía general de nueva york de
esta forma el ex mandatario evitó
responder las preguntas sobre sus
negocios realizados en la gran manzana
trump que en el pasado había criticado a
otros funcionarios para acogerse a la
quinta enmienda es investigado por
presuntamente falsear el valor de sus
activos para obtener préstamos y
exenciones fiscales la situación de
trump se produjo dos días después de que
el fbi registrará su casa campestre de
mar al lago en florida por una
investigación separada sobre si se llevó
a documentos clasificados cuando dejó la
casa blanca
poco después de que llegar a la oficina
del fiscal general de nueva york para
ser interrogado donaldson emitió un
comunicado diciendo que no tenía otra
opción que invocar la quinta enmienda
declinar responder a las preguntas en
virtud de los derechos y privilegios que
la constitución de eeuu se otorga a todo
ciudadano el ex presidente
estadounidense es objeto de una
investigación civil sobre más de una
década de irregularidades financieras en
la organización trump la multimillonaria
empresa que gestiona hoteles campos de
golf y otras propiedades inmobiliarias
la fiscal general de nueva york letitia
james ha citado importantes pruebas
contra el conglomerado familiar que está
bajo la lupa por proporcionar
información engañosa sobre sus activos a
las autoridades para obtener préstamos y
beneficios fiscales esta no es la única
medida legal en curso contra el ex
presidente la oficina del fiscal de
distrito de manhattan está llevando a
cabo una investigación paralela en la
organización trump que tiene el
potencial de imputar cargos criminales
mientras tanto su casa de mar al lago
fue registrada por el fbi y el lunes en
una investigación federal separada sobre
si retiro legalmente documentos
clasificados de la casa blanca cuando
dejó el cargo en enero de 2021
trump ha negado cualquier delito y ha
calificado las pesquisas de tener
motivación política de cara a su posible
candidatura presidencial de 2024 y de
vuelta a eeuu la presidenta de la cámara
de representantes nancy pelosi habló por
primera vez sobre su viaje relámpago a
taiwán y que generó toda una escalada de
tensiones con china la legisladora se
mostró orgullosa de su visita a la isla
y dijo que no fue allí para hablar del
gobierno del gigante asiático sino para
apoyar a taipei y respecto a los
ejercicios militares sino cerca de
taiwán que ya terminaron advirtió que
eeuu no puede permitir que brillen
normalice este nuevo nivel de presión
en perú el abogado del presidente pedro
castillo veni espinoza anunció en
twitter que vuelve a defenderlo tras
haber renunciado horas antes entretanto
se entregó a la justicia a jennifer
paredes cuñada del presidente pedro
castillo la corte suprema de justicia
había emitido una orden de detención el
martes por lo que también registró el
palacio presidencial la justicia peruana
buscaba a paredes por señalamientos de
corrupción y lavado de activos que
también salpican al mandatario de ser el
encargado de dirigir la castillo
calificó el proceso de un show mediático
informe de luís muñoz
se entregó la cuñada de pedro castillo
jennifer paredes acudió al ministerio
público después de dos intentos de
detención este miércoles la policía de
perú había entrado en la casa personal
del presidente en tacabamba el martes lo
hizo en el palacio presidencial donde la
justicia nunca había accedido para una
detención la fiscal general de perú
rechazó un plan político rechazó
firmemente las afirmaciones e
insinuaciones de que el ministerio
público
forma parte de un supuesto plan político
trabajada como una hija para pedro
castillo el martes la corte superior de
justicia emitió una orden de detención
contra jennifer paredes por 10 días y
por supuestamente participar en una red
de corrupción y lavado de activos
consideran que el presidente es el
cerebro el martes dos representantes de
una empresa licitada por el estado en
2021 fueron detenidos también un alcalde
de cajamarca la región del presidente
considera que hay una persecución ciega
a través de esa agenda mediática en ese
show mediático coludidos
con sectores que nunca han hecho nada
por el perú quieren doblegar nos se le
acumulan las crisis a pedro castillo la
fiscalía inició cinco investigaciones en
su contra cuatro de ellas están activas
superó dos mociones de censura en el
congreso y ha tenido decenas de
dimisiones de ministros su desaprobación
es del 67 por ciento marcada por
escándalos y por la ingobernabilidad con
una mayoría conservadora en el congreso
de estos parlamentarios incluso están
peor vistos con un 85% de desaprobación
y con el 65% de la población pidiendo
elecciones anticipadas
la esperanza de los familiares de los
diez mineros atrapados en una mina de
carbón en el norte de mexico se avivó
luego de que lograran ingresar los
primeros brigadistas militares para
revisar los túneles sin embargo aun las
condiciones no son óptimas para un
rescate pues todavía quedan obstáculos
en el pozo donde pretenden ingresar y
hay riesgo de un desplome mario carbón
el corresponsal en ciudad de mexico nos
daba previamente más detalles
se cumplió ya una semana de que quedaron
atrapados 10 trabajadores de una mina de
carbón en el municipio de sabinas en el
estado de coahuila al norte de mexico
después de días de maniobras para
intentar extraer en la mayor cantidad de
agua posible de estos pozos que quedaron
inundados
finalmente la tarde de este miércoles
logró ingresar en el pozo número 4 un
equipo de rescatistas de la marina y del
ejército mexicano en una cápsula de
inmersión también conocida como cápsula
de vida sin embargo este ingreso ha sido
intermitente es decir entran y salen y
han constatado que aún hay obstáculos
hay una cantidad considerable de basura
y de escombros que impiden un ingreso a
mayor profundidad que permita ya también
la entrada de los buzos para lograr dar
con el sitio donde presumiblemente se
encuentran atrapados estos mineros en
las afueras de estos esposos ya se
encuentra pues su personal médico y
ambulancias dispuestos para brindar
atención y primeros auxilios
los mineros tan pronto como logren salir
la idea es rescatar los ese es el plan y
los familiares no pierden la esperanza
se cumple ya una semana y en las
próximas horas serán decisivas
nueva jornada de manifestaciones
ciudadanas en argentina movimientos
sociales de izquierdas se manifestaron
frente a la casa rosada sede del
gobierno argentino ubicada en el centro
de buenos aires
estos movimientos reclaman mejoras
sociales que consideran urgentes también
piden reunirse con el nuevo ministro de
economía sergio massa los manifestantes
han afirmado que su intención es la de
quedarse en este punto céntrico de la
capital argentina por tiempo
indeterminado hasta que el ministro se
manifieste
y después de seis días de lucha contra
las llamas fue controlado el enorme
incendio en una base de depósitos de
combustible matanzas al oeste de cuba
pese a que las llamas fueron controladas
el riesgo en el lugar persiste el que es
considerado el mayor desastre industrial
de la historia dejó de cuba' dejó un
muerto 128 heridos 14 desaparecidos y
daños que todavía están por ser
contabilizados en los cuatro depósitos
afectados de un total de ocho de 50 mil
metros cúbicos cada uno todavía
permanece en algunos puntos activos en
donde los bomberos trabajan para
sofocarlos y reducir el riesgo de nuevas
conflagraciones
y finalizamos con información deportiva
porque ya se conocen tres clasificados a
las semifinales de la copa libertadores
en la jornada de hoy en duelo de equipos
argentinos vélez venció 1 a 0 a talleres
en brásil en el partido de la fecha
palmeiras clasificó tras vencer por
penaltis al atlético mineiro este jueves
se define el último clasificado entre
estudiantes de la plata- y el atlético
paranaense un torneo continental
dominado por los equipos brasileños y
argentinos
hasta aquí este informativo en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]